pancakes why do you only eat them in
February once a year Shrove Tuesday
which is crazy this is an american-style
pancake light fluffy and absolutely
delicious start off with 160 grams of
flour we sift the flour as you pour into
the bowl baking powder
it keeps the plain cake really nice and
light and fluffy salt 3 eggs
75 mils of water and a hundred and
twenty mill of buttermilk and the secret
behind this pancake mix is to make sure
that we've got no lumps anywhere whisk
the eggs into the flour get more
buttermilk just add half of it then give
a really good whisk that's nice and
smooth already the rest of the
buttermilk and when you make your
pancake mix like this it's chemistry so
follow the recipe exactly now we've got
this really nice smooth batter that's
ready to perfect nonstick pan sunflower
oil and run that round half a ladle in a
minute or half on each side absolutely
beautiful on to the plate this is where
it gets really exciting
we're can rising bananas it's important
to slice them lengthwise in order to
make sure that they don't go mushy in
the pan I'm gonna make a really nice
quick caramel 50 grams of sugar back off
the heat and start the camera don't
whisk it don't put spoon in there just
leave it in the pan once you're happy
with the color take it back off the heat
butter bananas I wanna do now is the
glaze the pan with some run-run banana
camera goes brilliantly
lovely think of the flavor the little
cup of water just to let the caramel
down so it's not too sticky and rich and
too thick there we go
that's ready be gentle with them because
it is just the ultimate in Dalton and
then finally to finish it some really
nice ice cream on top
and drizzle that over very very quick
and easy Scotch pancakes caramelized
bananas with rum and vanilla ice cream
done beautiful then one of the Americans
are so [ __ ] fan slightly tilt a knife
down
one at the top and they're gripping the
onion like a tennis ball holding it
together in place